-Well, here's a sentence
I never thought I'd say --
Donald Trump was arrested
and appeared
in Manhattan Criminal Court
to be arraigned on a total
of 34 felony charges.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, it happened.
Trump surrendered
himself to authorities today
and was arraigned at
the Manhattan Criminal Court
on charges stemming from
his hush-money payment
to adult-film-star
Stormy Daniels
during the 2016 campaign.
That's him in court.
Look at his face.
[ Laughter ]
This is the first time
in his life
anything's ever dawned on him.
[ Laughter ]
The day began with tense scenes
in Lower Manhattan
as throngs of Trump supporters
numbering in the tens
or perhaps even the twelves...
[ Laughter ]
showed up to sort of
just mill around, I guess,
support the former
indicted president,
where they were outnumbered
by both reporters and pigeons.
Outside,
agitator Marjorie Taylor Greene
showed up at a nearby park
to scream
and shout like a lunatic,
something only a tourist
from Georgia
would think gets her attention
in New York City.
New York Congressman
George Santos
also showed up,
where he claimed
he was the one who had sex
with Stormy Daniels.
Then --
[ Laughter ]
Then came Trump Watch.
The media had cameras
trained on him all day
like a panda cam at a zoo,
hoping to catch
a panda having sex,
and then illegally funneling
a hush-money payment
to the panda
they had sex with.
The cameras even
followed Trump's car
as it drove on the FDR Highway,
a parkway so slow and irritating
that if they really wanted
to name it after a president,
they should name it
after Donald J. Trump.
[ Laughter ]
And then came the moment
when Trump appeared
at the courthouse
and history was made.
Even Trump himself
seemed shocked.
-Just minutes ago,
a "where were you when..."
moment.
Donald Trump
now technically under arrest.
A former candidate who ran
for president amidst crowds
yelling for the locking up
of his then Democratic opponent,
Hillary Clinton,
has been arrested himself.
He says,
"Heading to lower Manhattan,
the courthouse, seems so
surreal" -- in all caps.
"Wow.
They are going to arrest me."
The former president writes,
"Can't believe this is happening
in America. MAGA!"
[ Laughter ]
-Trump commented
on his own arrest,
a watershed moment
in American history,
the way your grandpa
posts on Facebook
about his trip to Italy.
"Wow. Seems so surreal.
Can't believe the pizza
is better at home.
Your grandmother says hello."
[ Laughter ]
It's worth stepping back
and appreciating
just how crazy this was.
Today, we witnessed
the surreal spectacle
of one of the world's
most notorious figures,
a former president
and current candidate,
facing arrest and arraignment in
the media capital of the world.
And let's not forget how funny
"current candidate"
is in all this.
He got arrested, and he's still
running for president.
This is like Pennywise
doing kids' birthday parties
after "It" came out.
[ Laughter ]
Even before today, the media
speculation was so intense,
cameras followed his plane's
every movement, from takeoff
in Palm Beach
to landing at LaGuardia.
Man, look at that.
The media was tracking him
like he's their GrubHub order.
"Folks,
we're hearing now that Donald
is eight minutes away
with our burrito."
[ Laughter ]
I didn't think there was
a fate worse than prison,
but then they made him land
at LaGuardia.
[ Laughter ]
"So where are we touching down?
Teterboro? White Plains?"
"LaGuardia, sir."
"LaGuardia?!
I'm not on trial for murder!"
[ Laughter ]
"It's worse than that, sir."
"Spit it out!"
"We're landing
at the Marine terminal."
[ Laughter ]
Also, side note --
LaGuardia is nice now.
They did a great job
with the renovation.
Unfortunately, it's just
gonna take us a few years
to stop making
LaGuardia jokes.
So, LaGuardia, we just ask
for your patience
in the same way you asked for
ours during what seemed like,
I don't know, a hundred [bleep]
years of construction.
[ Laughter ]
The point is, LaGuardia --
[ Cheers and applause ]
LaGuardia is proof that even
the worst parts of New York
can change...Donald.
Now...
[ Laughter ]
Nice to know that LaGuardia
is still a very funny
arrival airport
for a former president.
Did he also have to wait
for his luggage at the carousel?
I would assume an oversize
gold-plated roller.
"We got your bag, sir."
"Double check the tag."
"It's definitely yours, sir."
"Check the tag!
They made an announcement.
A lot of these bags
look the same."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm gonna follow the rules now!
Okay?
That's the new Donald."
[ Laughter ]
Also, I want to make it clear.
It's not that I'm, like,
thrilled that a former president
has been indicted.
I'm not. But I am thrilled
that it's opened a door
to do topical jokes
about Donald Trump
flying into LaGuardia.
I mean, was there a driver
waiting for him there
with his name misspelled
on a placard?
[ Laughter ]
It's one thing to track Trump
as he landed
in New York yesterday
as he was ushered downtown for
his arraignment this afternoon,
but why do they watch
his plane take off
like it was
an Apollo Moon mission?
Did they think
there was a chance
he was going to rush
the cockpit,
grab the controls,
and make a hard
right turn toward Saudi Arabia?
"We have breaking news.
Trump has commandeered
the plane,
and it is now upside down."
[ Laughter ]
In fact, cable news
even went so far as to show us
Trump's luggage coming off the
plane on a conveyor belt Monday.
-The luggage is starting
to come out from the bottom.
So, my -- my guess is that they
don't want to get off the plane
until the luggage
is in the car,
so that way they can
just come down the stairs
and then be ready to go.
-Or Trump is trying
to smuggle himself
out inside
one of those suitcases.
[ Laughter ]
That's why when the luggage
came down,
the carousel kept making
these weird noises.
-Ouch.
[ Laughter ]
Mm.
[ Laughter continues ]
It's also the first time
I saw it, you guys,
and I'm...
[ Laughter ]
Now, when we were at first
speculating about this case,
I think most people imagined
it would be one or two charges
of maybe falsifying
business records
or campaign-finance violations.
It was then reported
that Trump would face 34 counts.
But even that was unclear
because that could mean,
say,
one felony and 33 misdemeanors,
which might actually come off
as a fairly weak case.
But we found out today
that the charges
were way more serious than that.
-NBC News is now reporting
that inside that courtroom,
Donald Trump pleaded not guilty
to 34 counts
of falsifying records.
-Our team, Aaron Katersky,
John Santucci,
Katherine Faulders,
all joining and reporting
at this hour
that the indictment
is 34 felony counts
of falsifying business records.
We don't know
if that is all of them,
but at least 34 felony counts
of falsifying business records.
-Not just 34 charges,
34 felonies!
Holy [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
In order to raise the $130,000
he used to pay off
Stormy Daniels,
did he also rob a bank
and a Halloween mask?
Of course, knowing Trump,
he'd wear a mask
of his own face,
although his actual face already
looks like a Halloween mask.
If you rip that thing off,
you'd probably find
Patrick Swayze
from "Point Break" under there.
Must have been a bummer
for Trump's team
to find out that there were
34 felony charges
because as recently
as last night, his lawyer,
a guy named Joe Tacopina,
was boldly
predicting on Fox News
that the case would
go away quickly.
-If it gets to a jury.
You know, what I would do,
what our team would do,
what Todd and Susan would do,
is simply look, you know,
the jurors in the eyes and say,
"This is -- You understand
you're not voting
for a political office here.
This is not
a presidential campaign
or a gubernatorial campaign.
This is someone's
life and liberty."
This should be the quickest
verdict in the history
of the United States of America.
-First of all,
life and liberty
also sound like porn stars
he paid hush money to.
[ Laughter ]
"Stormy introduced me
to Liberty,
who introduced me to Chastity.
And next thing you know,
bing, bang, boom, 34 felonies."
[ Laughter ]
Also, I almost feel bad
for Rudy Giuliani
having to watch this guy.
That used to be Rudy's job.
"Yeah, he's pretty good,
I guess,
if you like tall and handsome.
You know, I used to be tall,
but then my limo hit a pothole
and my neck fell down
inside my chest."
[ Laughter ]
"It was on the DJT."
We saw something historic today,
and in many ways,
it was healthy to see business
unfolding as normal in New York
because this is how
a healthy democracy
and criminal justice system
should be functioning.
Donald Trump
will be presumed innocent,
as all criminal defendants are,
and the prosecution will have
to prove that Trump
paid off Stormy as well as...
-Life and liberty.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪